so we are outside of the Moxie hotel
Moxie are the people that uh flew me out
here for terror southern show we got my
homie Kevin left behind me right now
you may have known it as one of the
champions from the Cavs that's the world
NBA champions of the earth that's right
Kevin love how you doing man
cope yeah you kudu over here to the left
of us we have a fire fire person I call
it lady fire fingers but we bout to go
outside see what's poppin in there and
you know Moxie always throws it down you
know they're always down to have a good
time I heard there's gonna be free
drinks some crazy circus [ __ ] ball is
life
stop working
are you doing that wait
reached between my bed
oh my god how is that possible
that's awesome I feel like I'm a
heartbeat now
[Music]
like I said man doing it they got an
open bar this guy here with a green
light all to somebody's face
[Music]
get your freak on photos to you I have
no idea what the [ __ ] that means this is
get in bed with moxie doing it for the
instant we're thinking pink boa feathers
I'm good right pop on right here what am
I looking at head up by the pillows is
it wide enough to get everything right
now it's gonna go here I like it I'm
gonna try to be as sexual as possible
okay
ball is life we're trying to be cute
perfect Massa got everything souvenirs
[ __ ] all day I'm pretty sure
the people did a lot of sexy pages but
they're not half as attractive nor the
curvaceous I am so [ __ ] y'all deal with
it
ball is life I'm [ __ ] so go over
here at the crystal ball reading this is
some voodoo [ __ ] I'm trying to get my
balls right
that's a holy [ __ ] that's a dude just
get the [ __ ] out of it can I ask you
what's behind there bachelor there's a
password right the password is moxie
okay see oh so close
anyway eighty-three hits one of the
hints all right some say that it's made
from this material titties its silicone
right rubber balls silicone mapa titties
breast implants no this material
what is condoms me neither
rubber rubber duck oh really
Oh give me one second yes I get my balls
red I did fortune telling once before
but the last time I did I was [ __ ]
around and I don't think the person
liked it very much so this time I'm
going for real and I want this person to
really read my balls
hi good I have never done this before
this is amazing
do I just sit right here can I sit here
I'm going to and you have a winter stock
because they're kind of cumbersome can I
stop if you do if you have a question in
your mind don't kill me
you take your left hand get our pallet
here and say your name David David what
you're gonna do is you're going to
separate it into three piles
everything okay
trust me you know the excuse your
language at all you have that here what
you have built for yourself is a strong
foundation to build upon
okay this is what I like this behind
your mat no they don't they don't put up
with my attention phony-baloney this for
any people that are trying to make them
out they can see in a while yeah this is
like having a super powers and having
tons of inner work working up to do that
and we kind of spotted a lot my way the
fire she's called the mask cutter or I
like to pay the no [ __ ] card her
swords down because she doesn't need to
be active just like whenever she seen it
you just like you like yeah people do
say that about me no awesome guys
under everybody calls me yeah hahaha
thank you very much one word to describe
what's going on right now it's like a
grown-up frat party just saying I'm
gonna leave my backpack here because I'm
bumping into everybody it's getting a
little bit too hectic here's my pictures
once again I'm cute as [ __ ] just to let
y'all know you know what the password is
yes what is it
I guess a that didn't know I should
silicone my bad what is back there we
it's a girl
[Music]
right people are right in the deepest
darkest secrets under so essentially
what's happening is that he gave us a
clue which was very simple he was
pointing out a condom and it was like
that's the clue so for me I said rubber
it was supposed to be latex it was
pretty [ __ ] obvious but that's okay
because as I said before
Paula's life I got the hook-up she told
me what it was it was latex and the guy
told me he's supposed to give you three
hints the other than you what so
apparently I was told there's a person
here covered completely in latex and you
are supposed to write your deepest
darkest secrets on her with a
highlighter pen somebody wrote I am very
sly that is a very shitty secret not to
blow somebody's mind
I once murdered a man okay but so if you
guys know I fractured both my ankles
playing ball
my ankles on my weak spot someone write
my deepest secret on her ankle hopefully
she's not ticklish I'm not very like
close with my secret so here's something
that you guys may or may not know when I
was in third grade I used to have a huge
violent streak because number one I
didn't get along with a lot of kids so
when I was eight years old I got into a
fight and I was removed from the school
because I stabbed the kid in the face
with a pencil and I stabbed that right
through the cheek of his mouth and it
was one of those things that grew about
spike I felt really terrible about but
later on when I was in eighth grade the
dude found me and he jump me with three
guys so those were like here's one of
like the many secrets that I have but
this is fascinating
a little creepy but very fun and I gotta
calm down okay so there's a [ __ ]
snake they trying to play games I was
gonna told about this snake okay so you
get individuals in each of you in bed
with the same I got you you can't play
with me she put a snake in the bush I
play with me no they got the energy I
got it
building up the energy I'm hoping she
gets eaten first that's a me about
getting my snake evening she lost her
mind
great I'm good I'm look at this lady I
was comfortable I just saw Jungle Book
why are you doing this to me yeah oh you
gonna put me close this leg that's cool
that's good
nah I like to say please I got a I got a
phobia but I'm not sure I look sexy at
the same time oh my god I think the
snake touched me it smells fear oh I'm
shaking
and one mouth [ __ ] dug it oh my god
okay I'm gonna try that I think it's
touch a thing oh god oh god I'm gonna
say [ __ ] like this yeah look right up -
what is this oh [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
[Music]
we are over here at the moxie for not
only do we have people who have lady
fingers
we have also people who send their
vaginas yep
the difference between me and the ladies
they always stay prepared how many
different poses do they have here we
have the peace sign next we have the
head tail next we have the shimmy smile
there it is and it's work all right save
it in save it in okay and what am I
gonna be in the middle of the side okay
cool I'm trying to be a bad [ __ ] I'll
always put him next to a snake this I'm
just telling you I look juicy so
so you know me I'm like extra low-key I
love Tarun
the hospitality everybody at boxing was
super dope here's the thing though
a [ __ ] Hungary so I gotta go get some
grub so on Yelp the other night I was
doing a lot of research to find what
places I wanted to eat at night or what
places we're gonna be opening a little
later and the great thing about Yelp is
that you can bookmark your findings I
was checking out this place called
killer for boys it's kind of when you
look up like best places to eat and uh I
guess will you call this area the French
Quarter killer pull boys pops up so down
to try it out yo this is crazy dude I'll
tell you right now
we were just here earlier this morning
[ __ ] Bourbon Street was not poppin
like this I have seen some weird [ __ ]
I'm talking about titties just do that
was on some [ __ ] walked out to me he
told me to Deb I gave him a quick DAP
that thrown the piece out got freaked
out we're over here at wolfing this
quarter two sisters I think that's the
name of the restaurant they say they got
famous po boys but and [ __ ] forgot his
wallet so it turns out every place on
Bourbon Street was bars for you to have
an ID so we had to figure out to go to a
place that allows us in without ID so we
came here and you [ __ ] bastard but it
weighs we're on the move up ol boys you
originally wanted to go to killer
po-boys but that's not in the officers
right now so we'll probably hit that up
tomorrow so what food just came that was
super quick of course I wanted them to
try ugh now you know me and gobble I got
to get everywhere that I go we have a
shrimp po-boy it's not deep-fried this
time this is a shrimp remoulade
interested in trying that out it comes
the the gumbo comes with a delicious
Creole French baguette as we so called
and Ed got the smothered pork so
let's dig into that and see what's
poppin definitely good this one actually
has heat compared to the last one that I
had over at the gumbo shop this one
tastes more like the one that I made the
one in the gumbo shop was definitely
deeper in flavor the features here are a
little bit more rustic meaning for me or
what that means to me is that the the
selling features and the onion pieces
are a lot the chunks are a lot bigger so
you could access actually kind of a
mouthfeel to it
nevertheless I doubt if you get really
bad gumbo in New Orleans or knowledge
trip member bob po boy i they want to
come to a full board I think that's
going to make it is definitely the bread
the shrimp run a lot it's actually on
pole it's a cold stream sandwich which I
didn't expect but nevertheless really
good next up you guys ed decided not to
bring his ID think about it booth this
is the pulled pork kind of interested in
this don't know what to expect
holy [ __ ] I'm good
it looks really savory but I actually
had a sweetness to it they put some type
of sugar into it there's some loud
[ __ ] right there that's not
gonna knowing this [ __ ] [ __ ] this one
but delicious I'm trying to fight nobody
[ __ ] Massa delicious this is a big
reason why I don't go out anymore it's
because you can always control yourself
but you can't control other people you
walk around and you hear somebody
[ __ ] yelling out some racial slurs I
mean it doesn't happen a lot in
California but you know people want to
talk about something where they say you
know racism isn't alive it doesn't exist
anymore that's [ __ ] [ __ ] absolute
[ __ ] you guys are being completely
blind to it now for me because I'm a lot
older I have a lot of things on the line
man what's the whole point if I come up
to that individual and you know get into
a fight with him get into his face it's
really no point we literally were
walking out and this do walked up or
drove up when this truck knee goes hell
row like the most [ __ ] typical
sorriest [ __ ] Asian insult on earth
you know what I mean and we're talking
about you know Louisiana which is
incredibly culturally diverse
we're over here like often Bourbon
Street where there's a whole bunch of
Asian people a whole bunch of black
people but there's still that one
jackass that wants to do that quick
little Asian joke so it turns around he
just throws his [ __ ] cigarette at
doose's [ __ ] you which is the most that
we could do that's the reality the
situation man you tell me that [ __ ]
racism is alive what the [ __ ] was that
I'm pretty sure you wouldn't walk around
dropping the N bomb on somebody but you
be sure as [ __ ] say hello to us call us
a [ __ ] you know it is what it is man so
we're back here at the moxie we just got
done grubbing you know it was a
relatively good night you know this was
super dope but obviously you know you're
dealing with some racist [ __ ] out
there a couple of [ __ ] but you know
I'm just ready to settle in go back to
my hotel and just chilling kick it and
kind of let go of this aggression I feel
like I've grown up I think old David so
would have gotten mad would have stood
up said that to somebody but
I didn't said something to somebody
anyways but you know how much really
kickin and relaxed
make you will easy Anna I'll see you all
tomorrow
you
[Music]